so I because I've been staying home I've
been reading a lot so I have four
recommendations for you today of course
I hope you were staying home reading is
a great thing to be doing david
pakman.com slash recommendations you can
find today's recommendations and all of
my others and if you use the links on
that page to buy the books we get a
little slice of your amazon transaction
that's david pakman.com slash
recommendations ok this is one of the
best narrative nonfiction books I've
read hunting Aikman by Neal Bascom it's
the story of hunting finding and
capturing and ultimately trying and
sentencing to death of Nazi Adolf
Eichmann he was caught in Argentina
where I was born
living under the name Ricardo Klement in
1960 the story is incredible this is a
what Neal Bascom has done is incredible
there are 75 pages of footnotes all of
the interviews transcripts that Neal
Bascom combed through to create a
narrative story of the capture of Adolf
Eichmann I cannot recommend this more
highly fantastic non-fiction book you'll
love it ok number two new jack by Ted
Conover this is a book that was
recommended to me I don't remember by
who knew Jack guarding sing-sing is the
story of journalist Ted Conover who
wanted to do a story on being a
corrections officer sometimes
pejoratively referred to as a prison
guard and not getting access to the
training program and two corrections
officers so Ted Conover decided to take
the admissions test to become a
corrections officer after two years was
invited to go to the Academy did it and
actually worked at sing-sing prison up
upstate from a New York City it's again
an incredible narrative nonfiction book
it's almost twenty years old at this
point
excellent excellent book couldn't
recommend it more highly now for
something different I recently read the
book by his holy in
the Dalai Lama beyond religion it's a
very interesting take on how Dalai Lama
believes that you don't actually need
religion to create a sort of functioning
moral and ethical framework a lot of
religious figures believe religion is
the only way to a moral and ethical
framework and this is beyond religion
ethics for a whole world by the Dalai
Lama excellent interesting a very quick
read only about a hundred and eighty
pages read it in a few days and the
writing is is compelling it's
interesting and it gives a perspective
on how the Dalai Lama sees Buddhism
fitting into non I guess we would call
it a more secular ethics a more secular
moral framework very interesting and
then lastly I've been reading a lot of
sort of older narrative nonfiction liars
poker by Michael Lewis liars poker was
written in I believe it was the late 80s
or early 90s let me see here it was
written in having trouble actually
finding that page in any case it's a
story of Michael Liu in 89
Michael Lewis working for the
now-defunct Salomon Brothers in bond
trading in the 1980s it gives you
incredible insight number one into the
boys club that was Wall Street in the
1980s number two Wall Street has
definitely changed significantly since
this book was written and it's a very
very interesting inside look and
extraordinarily well written by Michael
Lewis that's liars poker by Michael
Lewis all of today's recommendations and
my years of recommendations divided into
fiction and nonfiction and other
categories at david pakman.com slash
recommendations if you're looking for
things to read as you self isolate
social distance physically distance this
is a great time to pick up some of my
recommendations david pakman.com slash
recommendations